how's it going everyone so I think we
might have caught on to something if you
are unaware of what I'm talking about
yesterday the Russo brothers posted this
picture on Instagram and Twitter with
the caption look hard
this of course sent the internet into a
frenzy and everyone started freaking out
and a lot of speculation obviously
happened about the photo many people
believe that the title is in this photo
again there is a lot of thoughts on it
if you want to hear them all check out
the video I did yesterday in the link
above also a reminder that I'm currently
doing a giveaway I'm giving away a copy
of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
a special edition poster and some
special memorabilia from our partners at
silk and cotton all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero if
you want to check out silk and cotton
stuff on your own you can find them in
the link below so I don't think the
title is anywhere in this picture I
don't think that's how they would reveal
the title however after talking to a lot
of you on Instagram and Twitter and
after reading a bunch of comments I
think we're onto something
I actually think that there is something
in this photo very well hidden that
gives us some major insight to Avengers
4 so if you look at the left side do you
see this machine looking thing right
here what the thing that says nachi
above it well turns out we've seen this
before
in Avengers infinity war that's right we
have it in this scene right here at the
Avengers headquarters so now we're faced
with another question what is it because
it is definitely the same piece of
equipment from this scene in Avengers
infinity war now I've heard a lot of
different things a lot of different
theories of what this could be some say
it's some type of jet engine another
says that it's a piece of the Hulkbuster
suit but one thing I've heard that I
think makes the most sense is that this
is somehow related to a quantum tunnel
not the really huge one that we saw in
ant-man of the wasp but the one
in the post-credits scene in the back of
the van in ant-man on the wasp this
makes sense because it has been said
that the quantum realm will play a huge
part in Avengers 4 widely believe that
this is how our heroes are going to go
back in time however nothing has
officially been confirmed about time
travel for Avengers 4 so perhaps this is
the Russo brothers way of telling us
yeah
time travel will be a big part of
Avengers 4 now that's probably a bit of
a stretch but there is no doubt that
this is the same piece of equipment from
Avengers infinity war and it must be
important if they thought to put it in
this photo and Tony was working on it in
Avengers infinity war now one thing we
did notice is that this set photo is
most likely the Avengers headquarters if
you take a look at the top of the photo
you can see what is probably some sort
of ventilation system you can see that
it has X's on it and then if you look in
this scene in Avengers infinity war
where Rhodey is talking to Ross same
exact type of ventilation system with
the X's on it so it seems like this set
photo is the Avengers headquarters is
this what we were supposed to find is
this what we are supposed to look hard
for so far this and that machine are
really the only two things that can be
proven to be found in this photo
everything else like the A's or the
spelling of in-game or the may being
written on the wall that's all just
speculation but you can clearly see
these X's are the same and you can
clearly tell that this machine is the
same machine so what do you all think
this means do you think this machine
could be a part of a quantum tunnel and
do you think that this is the avengers
headquarters let me know what you think
in the comments below and of course if
you have a different theory of your own
let me know another reminder about the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero thank you so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you